welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on the evil
life-destroying dark dimension that
david blaine taps into every time he
performs magic on the street that's the
only way he can do it i i don't know how
he does it it's one of my dreams to meet
david blaine so i can be one of those
people they're like oh my god
and then like walk away from him while
he like because i'm so shocked that's
real that's not a trick oh for [ __ ]
sake now if you meet david blaine you
have to like watch him sit in ice for
two days seriously he's not drawing out
cards anymore it's all these endurance
tests where's the good devil's magic the
good old days before he was dangling off
of like a skyscraper
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon hello mt yes let's talk the
magic that occurs in our universe and
why it's so evil and why you should
never trust any magician never they're
up to no good listen if a magician
approaches you on the street i'm in a
trench coat like hey what's in dark
magic always say no it doesn't even have
to be a magician if anyone approaches
you on the street with a trench coat and
says you want to see something you say
yeah go away
either way it's going to be just as bad
as dark magic i'll tell you that but
anyway
what's our big question for today
brandon well mt this phase of the mcu
seems to be all about the matching magic
magic magic magic
single song that has magic in it do you
believe in magic there we
[Music]
we should turn to a family matters
channel yeah you've got like eight
seasons to catch up on geez but as we
slowly keep learning more and more about
the mystical powers being unleashed on
moon night we keep wondering if the
magic we're seeing fits into some of the
categories of magic we already know to
be true in the mcu it all leads us to
this week's big question is arthur
harrow tapping into dark magic
we've seen several forms of magic
practice in the mcu and they often have
a color associated with them eldritch
magic and asgardian magic both have an
orange slash golden glow to them and
they're also a form of light magic that
tends to be used for defense and healing
and there's also chaos magic we've seen
wanda use over the years manifesting
itself with that red color and there was
also the magic we saw used by classic
loki to create the giant illusion of
asgard and that magic had a green color
in loki and there was also the magic
used in chiang chi that we've called
talo magic and that magic didn't really
have a color but mostly appeared as
moving wind the use of this magic was
tied to the actual village of tallow as
if it were you know like a wi-fi signal
or something but what about the dog
magic the concept of darkness in the mcu
because the concept of dark magic was
first introduced in the first doctor
strange film back in 2016 and the magic
was drawn from the dark dimension the
home of dormammu casilius used this form
of magic and we've also come to find
that the ancient one was drawing on this
dark magic as well to extend her
mortality which is a big no-no
especially to the strict rule follower
mordo so the power from the dark
dimension had a purplish glow to it that
seemed to carry over to another instance
of dark magic we've seen and that would
be from miss agatha harkness from one
division because agatha's dark purple
magic appears to be tied to the dark
hole though it's possible she was
tapping into dark magic before she even
got her hands on the legendary tone but
now let's talk about the magic we've
seen wielded on moon night because is
the magic that we see arthur harrow
using on behalf of ahmet a form of dark
magic here so let us look at the
evidence that we have so far in the
series to see if we can determine the
magic's true source let's you know
look at it on a superficial level and
just examine the color don't do this for
people do this only for magic we gotta
examine the color first all right only
for a matter of fact
exhibit a the purple color of the magic
because as we stated earlier dark magic
in the mcu has traditionally been
presented itself as having a purple
color now there is some slight semantic
difference to how dark magic is referred
to in doctor strange and in one division
because in doctor strange they were
drawing power from the dark dimension
and then in one division when we saw
agatha get kicked out of her coven she
was accused of practicing the darkest of
magic but i think we can safely group
these two forms of magic into the
greater umbrella of you know just dark
magic in general just dark magic yeah
that makes sense yeah the magic we've
seen arthur harrow utilize has presented
itself with a purple hue so going by
that color theory one would think that
the magic leads to the dark side what do
you think i mean that makes the most
sense right uh you know marvel's been
pretty good about using color to denote
things and
all this purple magic we've seen before
is usually pretty dark and evil right uh
and like you said you know they kind of
described their magic differently in
doctor strange and in juan division dr
strates presented a lot of new concepts
at the mcu that they later did a better
job refining and landing on a definition
of but yeah i mean you see purple magic
we're supposed to think dark magic right
and he seems like the villain he seems
like he's doing evil things with it oh
yeah for sure and i think that you know
especially with the color purple when we
go back to that flashback of agatha
harkness on trial by the other witches
we know that their power is blue whereas
agatha's is purple right so like we but
we know from just basic color theory
that to make purple you need blue and
red
so like what if
agatha was originally a blue witch and
then she got in contact with a red dark
substance like i don't know the dark
hold which is like because red is
traditionally the color of darkness in
the mcu with chaos so like maybe because
she was influenced by that she learned
the dark the red stuff blue plus red
equals purple no that make that that's
great and that makes a lot of sense i
still like we have this debate all the
time at the office like did agatha have
the dark hold when she was getting
kicked out of the covenant right like i
i tend to think she didn't have it yet
because i don't know why this one coven
and salem would have the dark hole to
start with they said she was practicing
the darkest of magics they never like
said like you took the dark rider you
know in doctor strange they're like you
read these spells from a book you
weren't supposed to read you know they
didn't really say that they said you
were practicing the darkest of magics
and i'm wondering especially with what
we've seen with wenwoo if someone was
speaking to
agatha from from a different dimension
and kind of teaching her magic maybe in
an effort to lead her to the dark hole
eventually because they wanted to get
their hands on the dark hole that would
be an interesting way that she comes
across and hopefully this series that
they're doing on disney plus is going to
show us more history of how she came
into contact with the dark hold and how
long she had it for but that makes me
wonder what you were saying mt about the
color theory is if maybe agatha had some
chaos magic inside of her right and she
wanted to be the scarlet witch and when
she finally gets the dark hold someone
there is like you're not the scarlet
witch and she was pissed and she was
like well then no one gets to be the
scarlet witch and she steals the dark
cold and devoted her life to finding the
scarlet witch and killing her because
she wanted to be the scarlet witch
because she want to be the prettiest
girl strong she did want that
she wanted that crown she wanted that
ground bro like if agatha arc just
pulled a carry and one is like oopsie i
don't even know what i'm doing and i'm
so good at being the scarlet witch and i
don't even know magic and and i got this
just like you how dare you literally i
would be blessed too if like if my whole
life was revolved around like magic and
being in a coven and here comes this
random girl it's like oh my gosh i'm
just depressed and i've changed reality
i'd be like ah give me that power you
don't you don't deserve it um
that's my that's for me i i feel you
agatha it happens that's what grown up
is all about mt you spent your whole
life playing video games and finally you
think you're good uh
you finally got a place in your life
when you you can afford to buy the games
and you play the games when you have the
time and you're an old man and then
suddenly some 13 year old comes on and
just frags you immediately because
you're too old and you're too slow and
they were born with your true life
my eyes aren't as good as they used to
be brandon i can't compete with my
children
it's not funny my reflexes they're too
slow
i'm getting killed my thumbs is so so
slow i have the the osteoporosis now i
can't move them i don't know what i'm
saying i'm only 30. here we go
all right so now let's move on to the
soul stealing aspect of things because
exhibit b the ability of dark magic to
steal souls because we've seen arrow use
the staff of amit to judge a person's
worthiness over their lifetime and
arthur harrow stated that the staff
contains a tiny sliver of ahmed's power
and he uses her power to drain the soul
from a person deemed unworthy the most
evil person of all an old lady i don't
know what she's done but it's probably
terrible she probably um just lied in
bingo um so this stealing of the souls
is very reminiscent of the soul stealing
that was happening in shanghai and the
legend of the ten rings because in that
situation the souls were being fed to
the dweller in darkness in order to
power him up and the dweller existed in
another dimension perhaps a dimension
that draws on dark magic and right now
ahmed is trapped in a tomb and harrow is
collecting the souls in an effort to
help release her so it's possible that
his soul stealing power is something
that is tied to dark magic yeah i agree
with that i mean you mentioned earlier
uh mt that you know aldrich magic and
asgardian magic it's like light magic
right it's mostly used for defense or
like heal somebody yeah you can make a
sword every now and then but that's when
you're pushed to your limits like for
the most part they're doing like good
clean magic to help people but this you
know
any magic that allows you to just suck a
soul a person's soul out of their body
cannot be good no it's got to be like a
dark magic uh and they you know that
whole plot in legend uh chongqi and the
legend of the ten rings was about like
stealing saul right to power up this
other beast and it it can't be a
coincidence that like this show too is
about like well we gotta take the souls
of bad people
we say who's bad you know it's up to
this cane to swing back and forth in my
little magic tattoo uh but it can't be
good right like taking these souls to
give to ahmet even when that person
hasn't died yet like in egyptian
mythology ahmed you know weighs your
soul or weighs
the worthiness of your heart after
you're dead right now like before you're
dead yeah this cannot be good i don't i
don't trust this
system yeah oh you're gonna do something
bad so we're gonna take your soul now
yeah no i don't trust that at all and
like i this i definitely do feel like
dark magic is in play here because like
that's basically what agatha did as well
like in bond division to those watches
oh yeah she sucked their souls out and
they were pruned out much like that old
lady was at the after harrow gun sucked
her out that sounds weird um oh my
goodness that'd be very disgusting um
[Music]
yeah i think that there's a there's
definitely link there because like in
just in terms of like the the nature of
darkness if you just think about
darkness in general blackness like the
color black absorbs light so like and we
both know that both agatha and wanda
have the ability to absorb magic
especially wanda at the end of
bonavision right absorbing all of
seemingly all of agatha's magic into her
body so like we know that wanda
potentially has the ability to suck
people's lives out as well just like
agatha did and just like arthur harrow
did so it seems like you know
whatever this dark magic is i feel like
it has its deep roots in red
dark chaos magic and like in and the
redness of that magic is what this
purple glow
is like it's part of that purple glow
because like i'll i have this other
theory where like the the blue part is
like tesseract energy and like that's
how like the magic can go
that's how that's how portals can be
made to summon little jackals right well
and you know the the red infinity stone
was the ether exactly the reality stone
and we saw how powerful that was and how
dangerous it was how it spread exactly
like consumed and it was tied to the
darkness of the primordial universe
before the light came in that's like the
type of darkness that their mom who
likes because he loves living in
darkness he's like all right cool i
don't need all this yucky i don't know
um light bulbs screw thomas edison um i
don't need that dude he's a stupid head
well yeah and whether he is a stupid
head screw thomas screw you edison he
did a lot of bad things i mean i like
light bulbs but other people could have
done it in a better way he killed an
elephant he killed an elephant that's my
biggest beef but yeah that does make a
lot of sense and it would seem like if
there is you know whether it's dormammu
or some powerful entity from the dark
dimension you know they've tried to
attack us physically and it didn't work
right you know you can't take us down we
got all these superheroes now so it's
like they're getting off the physical
realm they're like what if we just take
apart this dimension soul by soul and by
stealing all of its souls and getting
more and more energy we can become more
powerful than this dimension of earth
19999
that is like defending itself if we
sneak in the back door and take all the
souls away they won't be able to fight
us it's true and like there's and we
know from doctor strange one that
there's something about our planet that
is so delicious to dark entities like
dormammu and even you know probably your
dweller in darknesses because like they
were very very like hungry for uh
so there's something about you know this
planet that like it's just so good it
tastes great i think it's probably the
uh the new spicy chicken sandwich at a
popeyes um most likely um it's not fair
we gotta stop making these spicy chicken
sandwiches
it's too tempting to all the evil forces
out there gotta stop it you gotta stop
it
[Music]
which leads us to our exhibit c
the dark mark because we've seen the mcu
how those who tap into dark magic are
often physically marked by the use of
those powers like for example case alias
and his followers along with the ancient
one who had the mark of dormammu on
their foreheads because they tapped into
the magic from the dark dimension a mark
that i might add is the color red like
you know chaos magic
um and when agatha performed dark magic
spells her fingers would begin to turn
black which is kind of weird and you
know not like my black fingers just a
darker a darker shade of black things
like she like she had a a bag of black
cheetos
and started to eat
darkness flavored cheetos what does it
taste like
tastes like it still tastes like
cheese shadow now in moon knight we can
see a similar manifestation in the
tattoo scales that arthur harrow and his
followers have because we know that
arthur's tattoo is able to move and
demonstrate the outcome of the
worthiness test now while we don't know
whether the follower's tattoos are a
result of dark magic it's fair to assume
that arthro harrows is especially since
is able to move and glow sort of
different colors yeah that's crazy empty
the idea i like what you're putting
together there that like every other
instance of dark magic we've seen it
leaves a mark on the person yes and this
tattoo is like a whole new thing and
yeah i wonder if like all because we've
seen all the followers have the tattoos
they might just have a guy in the cult
who does that tattoo to people yes but
i'm wondering if you get the worthiness
test and you pass does it maybe leave
that mark on you
like to show that you've passed the test
and you're able to be in
the gang and obviously you know they
didn't finish the test on steven grant
so it didn't leave a mark one way or the
other but that that would be interesting
to see if like if there's someone there
like actually actually physically
putting those tattoos on people or if it
is left behind by the magic because
obviously arthur harris is a magical
tattoo right you know normal tattoos
don't do that no he can't be faking that
so yeah i love this idea that it is a
manifestation of the dark magic he's
using like it leaves behind something
physical on it on its user yeah i
honestly feel like you know this is just
me being wild this could be just as just
a result of dealing with chaos magic or
dark magic for too long it's like
because we know like once agatha and
once wanda
like ex like use a lot of chaos magic
that's when their hands start to become
black right and we also know from for
the dark world like the whole threat of
for the dark world was malachith turning
the world into darkness using the red
chaos of the ether and we know that we
when he started to do that things
started to turn black like the when when
the ethers started to touch things
things started to corrode into blackness
i think that the ether and chaos magic
are connected
these fingertips are corroding into dark
matter we sort of get that feel in the
the new doctor strange trailers when we
see defender strange with his really
cracked up hands it's like he used too
much dark matter and he started his
whole body is starting to become
corrupted because he he messed with
things that he didn't understand and the
things that uh people gave wanda too
much grief for um even though they just
don't know that it just drives you crazy
but anyway
that's my long explanation as to what i
think those love the dark corrupting um
dark marks are i think it's just chaos
magic and like the nature of um this
dark magic to like to suck out the light
out of light beings like us because like
we we have you know we're we're made of
star stuff we're just stars so like
we're just it's
absorbing the star material from our
hands to make it dark anyway the edge
i like it now exhibit d the jackal hole
which is
it's funny um hey that's uh that's it's
my friday night said i go to a random
bar find the jackal hole you know what
i'm saying arthur harrow is able to use
the staff of amit to open up a hole in
the ground and summon jackal beasts and
these creatures seem to be coming out
from another dimension and not just a
hole in the ground because i'm sure he
didn't have like a a basement of jackals
he's like all right open up the jackal
hole i mean
i think there could be hundreds of
thousands of evil jackals living beneath
us
but enjoy your lentil soup everyone
there's just evil jackals ready to kill
you at any moment and this could be a
nod that from them coming from the
underworld a region that ahmet is part
of in egyptian mythology and these
creatures could also dissolve away when
they are killed leaving no trace behind
on our realm which is great for you know
if you're a cg artist who doesn't want
to keep animating the jackal anymore
very convenient for example thanks
jackal for just completely disappearing
and i hit the dissolve button and i'm
done and here we go after effects done
yeah the interdimensional nature of
these beasts is another clue that they
could be coming from a dark dimension
and while we didn't see it actually
happen in one division the craters did
say that they wanted to show how agatha
harkness's rabbit senor scratchy was a
demon that could shift into the form of
a rabbit which is quite scary i'm glad i
didn't see that happen very scary i
would have to call my mom and my mom
would have done a series of haitian
prayers and now that would have been two
hours of my life gone i've been waiting
for that easter bunny with a shotgun
don't come around here easter bunny
yo i know you're a demon beat your
demons your demon eggs in my house
speaking of demon bunnies the one movie
that i refuse to watch is darny darko i
know that darny darkos is cult classic
to watch darty narco because i don't
like scary [ __ ] like that bro i can't do
it i can't do it it's creepy rabbit
should be cute so if these jackals are a
different form of demons it would be
another indicator that there is some
dark magic going on yeah i mean these
jackals they don't seem like they're
products of good light magic uh and that
they're definitely coming from
some other dimension and all the dark
creatures we've seen before are like
usually interdimensional beasts like the
dweller and darkness for instance
like he's a dark creature and he comes
from another dimension uh and yeah if if
arthur hale is
taking these souls to help power up
ahmet we still don't know where ahmed is
like locked away we know she's in a tomb
somewhere that arthur harrell's looking
for but is that like a physical tube on
in our realm or is she stuffed away like
in a pocket dimension
either like the underworld's a pocket
dimension or something like that in this
episode when mark spector goes into the
pyramid it seems like he's inside the
giza pyramid that's what steven says
right and they kind of cut to an outside
shot but the the gateway opens up in
another location and he's taken there
but you know none of the gods are there
right it's just their avatars because as
we've talked about many times all the
gods are stuck in the celestial
holopolis which is like a different or
the overvoid as mark says in the episode
or the overvoid sometimes it's called
that too yeah yeah uh and so they can't
come into our dimension so do you think
ahmet is like locked away in a different
dimension or is ahmed like physically in
a tomb on our on our earth or is the
tomb like a gateway to another dimension
that ahmed is stuck in you know i think
it would be really dope if it was a
gateway to another dimension like i i
really want to see the overvoid i want
to see the ocean it's got to be right so
much because like if all these
gods want to like you know
be a peeping tom on uh us human human
human humanities if all these gods want
to be peeping toms on humanity i want to
see where they're peeping from all right
i want to see where they're you know
just living opposite and just like
chilling i'm in heaven and it's not
helping us and like this is something
that gore the god butcher is going to be
pretty pissed out too because like the
gods is not interfering yeah in helping
mankind with all these terrible things
especially with like the celestials
destroying all the planets
yeah gore's not going to be happy with
the gods just being like oh yeah that's
totally fine but i also take it to be
the celestials are way above like god
yeah like the gods can do nothing
against the celestials we know that
right like they they're useless against
the celestials the celestials put the
gods there in in the grand scheme of
things right but i'm more concerned
about two is are these
they're they're not making the indian
out to be like super smart guys right
like this whole trial what a mess
i mean
dude you know how hard it is to go in
front of the guides as you said yourself
the last time you did it you got
banished you know mark just kind of
floats the idea of like let's get in
front of the gods and tell them mark's
bad or or arthur howe's bad and then
conscious like yep sure you got it let
me go grab it right now and get that
going maybe take like 10 minutes lay out
your strategy be like here are the
reasons why
he's a bad guy instead arthur harrow
shows up immediately like he was ready
for this and he was like this guy's
crazy
and that's not i'm not trying to be
offensive to anybody this is what arthur
harold was saying and the gods are like
yep you know what
this guy is right we we we're going with
this guy can't you you're banned baby
double band literally and then they're
putting them in a rock thing and it's
like guys get your story straight before
you go in front of the judge but it also
makes these gods out to look like dum
dums right who like don't care at all
what's going on which is a very
interesting way to take it it's like
they don't get worse to worship anymore
so they're like screw earth i'm i'm i
don't care like yeah you don't see you
don't see odin act no one cares about
odin anymore but he still loved earth he
was still real keen on earth so you like
this a lot hey some would say that these
gods have a little bit of an ego and
maybe that's why ego is called ego
you know it's so weird that these gods
just because they're not being
worshipped they're just like all right
screw them because like we see like odin
despite you know you know i think that i
think he went to earth around like 900
bc or a.d one of those points really a
long time ago and like he gave humanity
the tesseract to guard and that's why
red skull was able to find it later on
and so like i wonder
if like the asgard was like hey even
though people don't worship us anymore
it's okay i don't know i don't i don't
the the enemy they just seem like
they're real you know
they they're real butt hurt about the
whole situation and like they're not
taking things seriously here yeah so
yeah i i think i think you're right mt i
i think ahmet's locked away in like
another dimension another separate
dimension and like this tomb is just
like a doorway to it
and if they give if arthur gets her
enough souls she'll get strong enough to
break out of her tomb they can open the
door on our end she'll be strong enough
to come through and she'll start eating
hearts baby yeah eating hearts that's
when uh sora donald goofy will come and
stop her um this is kingdom hearts
she'll turn into a big heartless that
would be funny if if disney's big goal
is to just like they're buying up all
these properties like marvel and star
wars and fox just so they can all put
them all inside of kingdom hearts
did you see the new kingdom hearts 4
trailer man
oh i saw it bro there's a little uh
foot in the trailer there's going to be
star wars in it bro i'm so excited yeah
so what is the strongest evidence we
have now that the magic that we see
arthur harrell using is dark magic so
like what do you think like is this the
era of dark magic in the mcu brandon i
mean it's gotta be right this
everything's leading up especially to
this doctor strange in the multiplayer
absolutely
we're gonna see that dark hold again
we're gonna see all these like other
interdimensional creatures like this is
the time of dark magic absolutely
full stop i hope it leads to dormammu
coming back i think that's like the big
end game here oh yeah like skrukathon
screw all that like bring back dormammu
and he's pissed yeah and he wants to eat
earth for real this time i honestly feel
like doramamu could be
a secret huge influence behind this
because he got rejected from eating
earth and so he's gonna want to try
again he's gonna give a damn about a
bargain he's gonna try a different way
to get back to earth and wanda is
probably the best way to do that so yeah
i can definitely see dormammu um
becoming a huge factor but yeah i think
that we're in a new
dark chapter in the mcu phase four is
going to be so dark heavy because like
i've said before in the past we got the
ebony blade from eternals we got the
symbiote coming in spider-man 4. we got
gore the god butcher's necro sword gonna
be a huge deal agatha harkness is
getting her own show um we have the ten
rings from from shanghi having this
access to dark creatures we have all
these dark artifacts and dark things
happening in the mcu that we need to if
you want to predict what titles are
coming next it's probably going to be
dark related and i honestly think that
captain america five remember when they
tease serpent society and people were
like well serpent society there was an
actual civil war i think we could be
seeing the cul upset coming into the mcu
and uh you know factoring in in captain
america five because why not bring back
the dinosaurs bring them back yeah yeah
savage land too even though that's not
really dark i just like dinosaurs oh
yeah that's what's inside the flip yeah
i feel like arthur i was gonna become
the shadow night man because shadow
knight's in the comics and it's dark
he's a dark man now guys time is running
out to grab yourself the moon knight
latest obsession shirt from
newrockstarsmerch.com it's called tomb
of the moon god and buying it not only
directly supports us here at new
rockstars but it also unlocks the
ability to get a shout out in our weekly
inside marvel show so get it before it
sells out at new rockstarsmerch.com it's
a really great shirt literally my
favorite design that we have so far and
it's going to sell out so go really
quickly now before we dive into our bite
size questions next some words from the
people that help bring big question to
you people like avast because the folks
over at avast are global leaders in
cyber security and have been for more
than 30 years avast is trusted by over
435
million users no matter who you are
where you are or how you connect they
are taking care of you on your terms a
vast new all-in-one solution avast one
helps you take control of your safety
and privacy online through a range of
features and learn more about avast one
at avast.com a few of the great features
that avast one offers include a great pc
speed up feature to optimize computer
performance and a smart scan to find and
remove viruses and what we like about
avast one here at new rockstars is that
they take care of everything in one
package no need to get different
software for antivirus and firewall
protection a vast one has you covered on
both ends so thanks to avast for
supporting big question in a vast
prevents 1.5 billion attacks every month
and with a vast one you can confidently
take control of your online world
without worrying about viruses phishing
attacks ransomware hacking attempts and
other cyber crimes so learn more about a
vast one at avast.com if you're looking
to chill out a bit but don't need to get
totally zombed
mellower vibes are a drop or a toke away
with dad grass dad grass is legal
organic smokeable hemp that relaxes your
body and mellows your mind they're 100
organic pre-rolled joints are very low
in thc and high in cbd so you can enjoy
the effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head chill out without getting stoned
it's like having a glass of wine not the
whole bottle if you're having a whole
bottle of wine just by yourself in a
couple of hours
slow down
want to choke without the smoke dagrass
also has a cbd tincture made with the
same high quality hemp it's easy to dose
and the effects come on smooth all dad
grass products are federally legal for
ages 18 and over and it ships right to
your door anywhere in the united states
the new rockstar staff has sampled a few
of the dad grass products and let me
tell you we enjoyed them the tincture is
great before bed confirmed uh my wife
and i tried one of the pre-rolled joints
it was lovely nice whether you're
looking for a new buzz or a chill way to
enjoy an old favorite dad grass will
leave you in a euphoric mood right now
dad grass is offering our listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com
bigquestion so head on over to
dadgrass.com big question for 20 off
your first order that's dadgrass.com
big question
[Music]
nice
seriously it was great and i really
enjoyed it 420 dead grass am i right
420 dead grass i mean oh man now time
for our bite size questions
how many different pantheons of gods are
there in and outside of the mcu this is
from ajessel on discord thank you okay
okay we did talk about this a little
last week on big question but within the
marvel comics universe there are
different pantheons or groups of gods
that often mirror our real world groups
of gods right there's also pantheons of
gods that exist for other planets such
as the shiar skrull and the centurions
that's a couple of examples but let's
not include those let's stick with the
earth-based gods that would be
represented in like the council of
godheads right so going with just
earth-based pantheons and including the
multiversal god aka the one above all
praise him i found 29
different pantheons i'm not going to say
all of their names here but our lovely
editors can make the names scroll by as
i'm talking oh look at all play some
elevator music too all these different
gods
oh
oh a pooh of course oh the asgardians we
know them uh the dark gods yes yes yes
uh-huh oh some of them oh oh that one
too oh that's fascinating oh okay oh
wow okay oh so there they all are isn't
that fascinating now as for what we've
seen in the mcu so far we have a much
smaller list it's pretty much just the
asgardians heliopolitans the primordial
god aka uh the dweller and darkness the
eternals and the celestials like that's
it right those are the only god groups
we've seen in the mcu so there's plenty
of room for tons more pantheons in the
mcu but yeah there's a ton in the comics
and gods for like other planets it's
crazy so many so so so very much some
would say too many time for gore
too many gods
thank you for that brandon that's
actually a really big question that i i
i myself wanted to know because like we
just have a lot of god yeah i was
shocked how many there were the
wikipedia entry is just like massive
massive now brandon i got some emails
for you ready for this
brandon is there a purpose of a cape for
a superhero suit other than just looking
cool this is from alexa the editor who
asked us this on twitter thank you alexa
alexa alexa there's an a like the like
the device really nailed it ideally now
that's why they pay me the medium bucks
thank you alexa for sending in this
question
this was actually a great question yeah
as i got into it so as edna mode from
the incredibles made the trend of cape
hating popular again no capes no kicks
this was also a sticking point for alan
moore and the watchmen r.i.p dollar bill
is there really a purpose for heroes
having cakes like why why even bother
having these capes of course your cape
could be imbued with powers and
abilities like dr strange cloak of
levitation or the cloaks cloak you know
the cloak he's got a cloak yeah is a
cloak of cape i'm gonna count a cloak as
a cape yeah but yeah so sometimes a cape
has like very practical purposes it
gives you more powers it has abilities
of its own even like uh you know the
invisibility cloak that harry potter has
again another cloak uh we're going to
count it we're going to have this there
is of course a way of having like a
protective case for heroes like batman
right he can make his cape bulletproof
fireproof or whatever kind of proof he
needs for the comic um and superman's
cape is also made of material from his
spaceship that he was found in as a
little boy and is also not
indestructible as jonathan kent found
out when he started blasting it with a
shotgun just to try it out like wow hey
i wonder if i can shoot this fabric with
a gun
boom like turn around clark i don't know
why
yeah
martha hold this up i need to shoot at
it
hang it up on the barn jonathan i don't
want to put holes in the bar martha hold
this fabric up
i'm gonna run into that tornado i swear
to god
i mean can we talk about how superman
just let his dad run into a tornado in
the dc eu one of the dumbest things i've
ever seen no offense to zack snyder but
like no
what are you gonna do like that like bro
if it was me just jonathan ken i would
have been like yeah save everyone's son
i don't care who sees you
this is your debut son run your ass over
here and get me out of this goddamn
tornado so yeah superman's got an
indestructible cape even though he
himself is indestructible so it's like
double indestructible ability on on top
of each other i don't know why um but if
you recall this event nbc even had a
whole last show around a hero called the
cat whose defining feature was that he
used a cape yeah
and this cape wasn't even a magic cape
he just incorporated it into his
fighting style and utilized it to
manufacture illusions to confuse his
opponent wow ridiculous of course there
are some practical cases of capes out
there but why did this trend even begin
why even seriously put superheroes i
blame superman well you're right on it
with the concept of modern superheroes
beginning in the 1920s and 30s it is
widely believed that their aesthetic was
heavily influenced by circus performers
at the time who would often wear capes
especially the acrobats and strong men
who would most influence the idea of a
superhero so yeah in the 20s and 30s you
know you go and see these circuses and
like these larger-than-life characters
doing these incredible acts like these
were the influence for superheroes so
they kind of like modeled them after
these acrobats and it's like these
strong men so these performers they'd
often wear like leather boots and a
leotard tight and revealing to show off
their form for the audience sound
familiar when they're doing these
circuses they're also performing like
outside or in these open-air tents which
could be quite chilly when they were not
on stage so their costumes often
included a cloak or a cape when they
were off stage to help keep them warm
but still in their character right that
and so you have this going on in the
1920s and 30s you have comic books
starting around the same time so that's
where this design idea came from there's
also the idea that when comics were
first being printed in the 30s and 40s
there were limitations as to how
intricate the drawings could be to
accommodate the printing technology at
the time
so capes are a very helpful way to imply
movement and direction when a character
was running or flying or falling etc so
imagine like superman like an old
superman comic if you just draw him like
this without like a cape you don't know
if he's flying if he's just standing
there or whatever so they could imply
direction by the way the cape was you
know blowing or rustling or whatever
finally there's yet one other theory
that the influence of capes on heroes uh
came from spanish folklore and the idea
of the kappa e espada or cape and sword
a lot of these heroes in these spanish
folklore had a cape and a sword the most
famous one being of course zorro who had
a cape a sword a mask and uh it wasn't
batman based off his zorro too uh yeah
batman has like strong influences from
zoro so those are the influences that
led to like the superheroes we know
today having capes just because of the
way storytelling was going at the time
uh you know the practical printing
applications uh and circuses so there
you go as for them having functions
sometimes they do most of the time they
don't and sometimes they get you killed
yep sucked right into an airplane engine
don't do it
suck right into that jet engine no i
really love learning about like the
whole circus roots of of superheroes
because yeah i feel like that's the
secret to what makes superhero movies so
great it's like if you if we just go
back to the to the roots of it it's like
people will like to see spectacle people
like to see crazy things happening that
they could never see that's what people
love spider-man so much for part of part
of the reason why because like he's
doing all these crazy flips and like
being like whoa i can't believe a human
can do that and i think that's what
people really love right like i love
that that's like sort of rooted into
what superheroes are because of the
circus roots i love that a lot um so
thank you brandon you're very smart i
love your research always
smart cookie hey welcome but now it's
time for a box of scraps question
brandon you ready
boxers
now brandon could perform one piece of
magic for real what would your spell be
what would my realistic magic spell be
[Music]
if i could do one piece of magic for
real i think i would like the ability to
make something like disappear and then
reappear you know what i mean for real
like i could just take something i could
put it away in a pocket dimension i
could bring it back whenever i wanted
that's pretty dope it'd be a great way
to go to the grocery store to you know
just you know right i don't want to pay
for that lobster tail just fine
so basically i'd become like a magical
kleptomaniac i guess
uh but yeah i think that that would be
the the magic power i would want the
ability to like you could just steal a
santa sack from the north pole that's
basically what that is
oh that's like doubling it up right
basically i think mine would probably be
i've always been into dreams a lot ever
since i was a kid so like having the
ability to like
you know take someone's dreams out and
like view it on like a tv screen it's
like oh hey you wanna watch your dream
on tv sure let's all watch it together
let's see how weird it was i would think
it would be gonna be messed up i don't
want people seeing my dreams i'm like
really scared if you found a way to like
to control your dreams you could
basically become like a movie director
and just be like all right i made a
movie last night here it is
it just showed on tv well there's those
people who work really hard at like
lucid dreaming yeah like being awake for
your dreams and like having control over
it then they always tell people like oh
i did it last night and you're like i
don't know if you really like i don't
you could be the one to prove empty if
people are actually lucid dreaming or if
they're just like lying and saying
exactly and like you know guys be like
oh baby i had a dream about you last
night i could be like oh did you have a
dream about your girl let's find out
were you lying let's find out i know he
was dreaming about bacon i can see empty
[Laughter]
like oh man he's got like infomercials
and tv's got infomercials on tv like did
your husband claim to have a dream about
you last night call me empty the dreams
here and we'll find out if your husband
is real or a liar we'll throw him right
under the bus did your man say he was
dreaming about you last night or was he
dreaming about bacon again call me mt
the dream seer we'll get to the bottom
of your dreams that is it for this
episode of big question as always huge
thank you to brandon for joining me on
this episode please follow him at grin
and barrack on twitter follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and more
importantly follow new rockstars here on
youtube and on all of our social media
platforms and make sure to hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you want to continue the
conversation our new rockstars discord
server is now open to the public so if
you're 18 years or older please click
the link in the description to join that
conversation because we love just
chatting with people on discord you guys
are the best
fans that we could ever ask for we will
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you